- [Voiceover] Kim, we've been
doing a couple of videos where
we saw how slavery became more
and more of a political issue
as we're going through the early 1800s.
You go all the way to
the Compromise of 1850,
the Fugitive Slave Act,
it really starts to anger,
especially, definitely
abolitionists, who are always
very against slavery
under moral arguments,
but, also, a lot of the anti-slave folks,
Republican party forums, and then we have
the election of Abraham Lincoln, in,
let's see, if we zoom in on this timeline,
this is from 1860 to
1870, we zoom in there,
and if we really zoom in on
the early part of that decade,
Lincoln gets elected in November of 1860,
which seems, at least
based on this timeline,
to start catalyzing a whole
chain reaction of things.
- [Voiceover] Yeah, this
is a time when things
happen really fast, Lincoln is
elected in November of 1860,
but this is before we have
our modern election timeline,
when presidents actually
take office in January.
Presidents in this time
period didn't take office
until March, so there is
this huge lame duck period
where everyone's kind of
wondering what's going to happen
when Lincoln actually
takes the presidency.
- [Voiceover] The current
president during the election
is Buchanan, and he's the lame duck.
Someone else has been elected,
and he has to kind of
pretend to be president
for, what is it, five months,
until the actual inauguration.
- [Voiceover] Right, this is
no president's favorite time,
when everyone knows that a new president
is going to be coming in, so
their influence is waning.
What's important in this
time period is that,
after Lincoln is elected,
and as we talked about
in the last video, without
a single southern vote...
- [Voiceover] He wasn't
even on the ballot.
- [Voiceover] He wasn't even
on the ballot for most places.
Southern states start to think about
what they're going to do,
so they know that Lincoln is
an anti-slavery president.
They think that having Lincoln in office
is going to be a direct challenge
to the institution of slavery,
so in this period of a few months,
from December, at the end of 1860,
to February in 1861, the southern states
think about what they're going to do.
They send commissioners around saying,
"Do you think we should secede?"
"Yeah, probably, we should secede."
So in this two-month period,
what they call the secession winter,
seven states in the South secede.
- [Voiceover] At this
point, did they think that,
this is an act of war by seceding,
or did they think, "Hey, we
can secede if we want to"?
- [Voiceover] I think
they don't really know
whether the United States
is going to act decisively
to try to keep them in the Union,
they're just waiting to find out.
- [Voiceover] At this
point, Lincoln is waiting
to become president, James
Buchanan is the president.
He's not really in a position
to do much of anything.
When does this become an all out war?
- [Voiceover] Lincoln
actually takes office in
March of 1861, and shortly
there after, a southern fort
off the coast of
Charleston, South Carolina,
Fort Sumpter, they let him know they're
running out of supplies.
So, this is a federal fort, which reports
to Washington D.C., which is in a way,
sort of trapped behind this enemy line
in South Carolina, the
state that has seceded.
So, Lincoln says, "All
right, well I'm going
to send you a ship to resupply you."
When the ship gets to
the Charleston harbor
southern forces from South
Carolina fire on the ship.
- [Voiceover] Lincoln
wasn't naive, he knew that
that these states had now seceded
for a few months,
especially South Carolina.
He knew that it was
going to be viewed as him
replenishing a fort, from their point
of view, on their territory.
- [Voiceover] Right,
from their point of view.
You could also have just
said, "Here's some hungry men,
I'm getting them some food, let me put
my boat into the harbor,
and we'll get them
their supplies and then I'll leave."
I think it was really
up to the southerners
whether they used this as an opportunity
to reject federal authority.
- [Voiceover] And was it just
food? Or were there arms?
- [Voiceover] Well, it was a federal fort,
so it was everything they needed
to keep this fort running.
- [Voiceover] So, it
seems like on both sides,
people knew where this was going.
If war breaks out, South
Carolina is going to say,
"Hey, we don't want
this thing replenished,
in fact, we want to take that fort. "
From their point of view,
it's on their territory.
Lincoln's like, "I'm not going to let this
whole secession thing go,
I want to replenish the
force that I'm probably going to need."
And then what happens?
- [Voiceover] So, after
the southerners fire
on this Union boat, Lincoln
realizes that this rebellion
is very serious and so he calls for 75,000
volunteers to come into the army
and suppress the rebellion.
- [Voiceover] This is shortly after the...
- [Voiceover] Right, this
is just days after the April
firing on Fort Sumpter.
- [Voiceover] so 75,000 volunteers,
which is massive by any standards,
but the country is a lot
smaller then than it is today.
- [Voiceover] Yeah, there
were only about 30 million
Americans at that time,
so the country is
literally ten times smaller
than it is today. So,
75,000 volunteers is a lot.
- [Voiceover] And then
what does that catalyze?
- [Voiceover] Well, now war
is serious. The United States
is gathering an army
and the southern states
know that this US army is going to invade.
- [Voiceover] From their
point of view its an invasion,
from Abraham Lincoln's point of view,
they're viewed as, this is a rebellion,
and we're just going
to quell the rebellion.
- [Voiceover] Right, so
the southern states think,
"We're our own country."
They've made themselves
the Confederate States of America.
Lincoln doesn't accept that
they're their own country,
these are just some states
that are in rebellion
as part of the United States.
- [Voiceover] At that point,
is it all out? We've only
had seven states secede.
- [Voiceover] Right, so
there are a few states that
are still on the fence after
Lincoln's inauguration.
They feel strong cultural
unity with the United States,
but these are slave states,
and so after Lincoln calls
for these 75,000 volunteers
that kind of pushes
them over the edge and says,
"All right, this is going to be war.
It's going to be a war over
whether slavery exists,
we care about the existence of slavery,
and so we're going to join with the
Confederates, in the
Confederate States of America,
and join the rebellion."
Most notable among these is Virginia.
Virginia is not on of the
original states that secedes.
Most of the action in
the Civil War is actually
going to take place in
Virginia, and Virginia's
greatest general, Robert E. Lee,
is then pushed to, in his
mind, defend Virginia,
and become the leading general
for the Confederate States of America.
- [Voiceover] Geographically,
it's right at the border,
obviously their home to
a major military figure,
and they were an
economically powerful state.
- [Voiceover] Yes, absolutely.
- [Voiceover] So then at
that point it's all out war.
- [Voiceover] It's all out
war, and in July of that year,
there's really the first
battle of the Civil War.
First couple of months, everyone
is just gearing up for war.
The forces of the United
States and the forces
of the South, finally meet in battle,
what we call the Battle of Bull Run,
which is in Manassas, Virginia,
northern Virginia today.
People really think at
this point that it's
going to be a crushing
defeat for the South,
in fact people don't even
really know what war is like.
There are stories that
civilians from nearby
packed a picnic to come
sit on a hill above
this battle and watch it, sort of like
we might watch a football game now.
They were quickly disillusioned of what
war was actually like, they had to
run for their lives because this was
a violent battle and it showed that it was
not going to be a quick war.
The South decisively wins this battle,
and from that point forward they know
it's going to be a very
long and bloody conflict.
- [Voiceover] You mentioned
the first seven states secede,
and then you have Lincoln
building up a real army,
then you have four more states secede,
even those some of these states feel
an affinity to the United States,
they are slave states,
but not all the slave states left.
- [Voiceover] Right, there are four
more slave states that stick around.
Most important of those is Maryland.
Maryland, of course, is right on the
border of Washington D.C.
- [Voiceover] D.C. is sandwiched
between Maryland and Virginia.
- [Voiceover] Right, and
so if Maryland leaves
and joins the rebellion,
then Washington D.C.
is in real trouble because they will be
completely surrounded by enemy territory.